[Music]
all right hey it's me hey Jake it's me
no I'm Jake hey everybody its episode
201 of the podcast and it's me Jake so
here you are and I've got a guess and
we're in the room Chris Martin thank you
thanks for having me mate this is 201 i
miss 200 x was out he was 200 200 was
Zoe Coombs more she knows yeah yeah
she's great oh sure was just on that a
my friends by chance when to watch it
and loved it yeah yeah so she reached
out because I love that show when I saw
it last year no Melbourne and so he
stopped by here and I sent my wife and a
bunch of other friends to go see it
because I was out of town but as in UCB
yeah yeah yeah you see be here and then
I think it's she's got one in New York I
think tonight as we're talking but not
tonight yeah I because that's not the
way that this medium works no it can't
everybody's gotta wait to be put on the
Internet yeah nothing will do do you do
it to you kind of reach we with our one
we we have got a backlog that we're
staggering so I felt that we had a guest
on yesterday and he's got a special
coming out this Friday I was like we're
not going to release this for like two
and a half weeks I mean we could raise
it but we've got a nice you know you
must stay the week we like to do it yeah
now I get it but you can catch up on all
these things now they can watch the guys
special on repeat yeah well that's the
other thing it's a bit a live show than
you miss it you miss it unless anyway so
let's start we're getting ahead of a lot
of tangent in this I can I know off well
girls there will be it's going to be a
lot of tangents because there's not
really a specific format but what we
should do at the beginning is you okay
yeah do me let's talk about you I could
have prepared a great introduction so
but I fell down on the job I did your
podcast yeah do with coral Donnelly yeah
the one of my friends that I met in
Melbourne but you are separate from him
you're not him I'm not him but I'm very
closely aligned with him we've been a
podcasting together for many years were
good were like
friends and could you have a best friend
in comedy yeah you know I I do did I do
did I this guy started out with at the
same time a long time ago were best
friends for the longest time and then we
both got married the same year which is
14 years ago roughly and then had kids
and now he's moved out of LA so my had
my best friend in companies it's harder
than it because he's hard as a grown man
to even out here like I feel like we're
getting a nice little French it was hard
too hard to make a friend as a grownup
like a new friends yeah it's not a new
like if you were used to give you'll
need a comedy you can make a new friend
but it's a bit difficult to like 10
years in be like hi well there was one
of the fun things about doing their
festival is because then you meet people
and then you kind of crossed paths with
them later and you've got a chance it's
more naturally that Zoe would say when
she was coming here oh hey I'm coming to
town so we can hang out yes like yes of
course but that moment when you meet
someone that you kind of think would be
fun to hang out with in a comedy club
around town where you live then to take
it to the next level I know how do you
go steady with that way you do well I
the festival is a great thing because
you're in this brilliant make-believe
world for a month where there's no real
responsibility or doing your show it you
have to show once a day for an hour and
that becomes life oh yeah and you hang
out afterwards and everyone's it's like
when your tuck of working holiday and
when you're abroad if you don't quite
know how to layer the land and how it
all works it's a grace the best time to
meet someone it was a good one well and
Carl was having a year were that was the
first time I had done a month-long
festival like that so I was staying in a
hotel that was kind of like a dorm for
comedians in a way there were a bunch of
other comics doing the festival of the
edina yeah that's nice though it was
nice it was really nice but Carl was
staying out in the neighborhood at an
Airbnb so he was having the like I live
here for a month experience oh right so
I would only see him at night post-show
hangout time and then we were meant to I
think we're going to try and do
something during the day but then that
never transpired he's a big fan of
walking around shops here big shopper
but like he makes sure i don't like
shopping he loves shopping mm-hmm but he
makes it kind of less I don't want to be
stereo I did you ever find in your
relationship with your wife that as a
nun newly married a year and a half I
hate it when I find myself falling into
the tropes of like she loves shopping
and I hate shopping and so I hate being
the guy shopping river looking at his
phone i wish like I could be more
subversive and interesting but sometimes
I might I just hate I just hate it you
mean just go along and kind of just
going along and we hate it yeah but she
knows I had when we first I going out
the first three months we'd be like free
time where we go and then eventually had
to just drop the facade as I can't she
couldn't understand I didn't I shopping
like it was it was absolutely alien to
her but at mine of car you can do it in
kind of a stealthy yeah it's more like
registered and performers cool shot but
she's like proper touches every item
asked my opinion and everything I had
this good thing this is going to sound
very odd and might mean nothing to you
but in the shop she goes into there is a
necklace where there's everything I've
done it I'm just turning it down a visit
I'm allowed guy I'm allowed I more like
yes there's a necklace made of metal
chains they have the kind of little thin
chains and if you just gently put down
your hand thin chains because it
collapse into a tower or do you make it
into a you just sort of it bring it down
and just sort of gently sits like it
just cook it just sort of falls into
itself and it's one of my therapeutic
things you can do in a shop and so is
that an experience that you can have it
a lot of metal chain sharp sir this one
specific etch a metal should know at
most high street shops they have a
jewelry section right in the jewelry
section you can normally find a kind of
it's very thin chain mail and it's kind
of long when you put it down and just
gently sits and it's just got a nice
feel yeah I go straight to that section
now sounds nice I wish we had more time
after this to go down there's a jewelry
place right panel sorry dear yes on Main
Street we call it Main Street but you
call it the house unless to it I'm just
explain it to the music
they need help a little bit cool the
high street we just got medical pot here
so we don't you go we didn't get we got
recreational we had medical but they
don't yeah it's quite how do you go to
college no I didn't get certified
because I'm a little bit too paranoid I
didn't want to be on the list you know
that's what that's the first because
it's will also paranoid from what you
would be more power than having the weed
the pot makes you paranoid but then I'm
already paranoid too I'm predisposed to
it alright higher load of being like on
a register I'm on the yeah because your
information because it's legals by the
space but it's still federally illegal
so in that sense if the federal
government decided look we're going to
we're going to drug busts people the
first thing they're going to do is get
get the list of people who got pot from
the state and then that's where we'll go
that's a really good point all they
could suddenly could they make it
illegal again here vay specifically who
everyone they make sure you got the
first houses to hit just on all of this
they know where to go yeah not that I I
don't realistically think that's going
to happen but I but I'm not as big of an
advocate of pot I'm not the kind of guy
who's like oh I need to get on that list
I'm the kind of guy who like once in a
while yes that feels like I mean over
here it does make me laugh how does if I
explain this you for in the UK we do
something we call it we call it spliffs
so that we roll it with tobacco and you
have it typically between age of 14 and
16 then you grab it then you don't smell
spot any well there are the odd person
but like no and I really know everyone
so did it for a bit and any such
drinking booze more and then people
start not people like me because I'm a
bit more clean-cut than the people start
taking ecstasy and cocaine and weed is
seen as but also it's definitely not as
strong as over here so they're here it's
like a higher quarter so I think it's
more of a UK I don't know how much it
costs I've never bought drugs off a drug
dealer so yeah me neither one up for a
long time yeah i was in college so
that's a long time ago yeah that's
pretty unreal dealer and college is it
like a guy in a dorm he's got like a
great way you know what I mean yeah yeah
well right I've never gone to score from
a stranger you
with hiring I terrified that people to
do that there you go ring a guy sit in
his car and I mean Hannah why you
wouldn't get I know this by the way but
they know you can't dump them in because
you have to admit the evening by enjoys
I and I also think it's a little bit of
a dangerous thing like if you you're not
going to call the police on honor on the
ghost on your parcel you know unless
you're being here if you didn't you'd be
testifying for your own immunity but
even then you don't to get mixed up in
that so yeah well I don't live like I'm
gonna live vicariously through Carl
who's very much the bad boy of our
relationship eat only a story a few
couple months ago where he was on a stag
do where he got off the rails and he
went to buy some sort of narcotic in an
alleyway got off the rails off the rails
of another year I no no no I get it but
but it's I mean that's more than after
well I find you know by narcotic that
just seems like wow yet really he's not
even he's not even near to change i get
another thing that maybe wasn't a
product there could be second beans what
could there be I've made that sounds I
mean doesn't matter he's admitted this
himself say it was cocaine he's admitted
saying all right well so that he said
that's very different when you say
narcotic I think heroin which is I
thrown out of well that's what I yeah
I've got your right to heroin see here
cocaine is one of those things like you
smoke your part you have your alcohol
and then some people just go to that
next level with cocaine it's not a I
mean it's don't get me wrong I think so
it's going to be a mistake it's not a
good idea who suffer in your code card
or you could be it up but he said he
went to an alleyway tonight of some kind
Russian I was in like Estonia something
I know is a really big bald guy anyone
you're a sample it and then the guy got
a machete out put a bit on the end of
his machete let him have it off the
machete and I was like lies that as a
real power play that there's no way
you're not buying that drug after that
guys he didn't like threaten him but he
was like have some of my drugs and i
also have a machete well and also and
also if you were thinking about trying
to rob me or turn me in to the police
yeah i said just i have a machete what
else do I have and that would be great
in so many other aspects of life just to
just I'm not going to threaten you but
just be aware that I have a machete on
my person now on stage that'd be nice
you know me
I don't know do you think if you ever
get drunk people just just slightly show
me inside a jacket go machete in there
that's interesting because I do feel
like here sometimes you can think of the
crowd if they're drunk as is hostile a
little bit but I didn't sense that as
much when I was in the UK is it it
seemed like if they were if they were
screwing with you it was more kind of
good-natured as opposed to mean yeah
that's the British find that it's taking
the piss is the kind of so it's like a
hazing thing like make me laugh all
right yeah you've done all right there's
hackling because they like prove prove
that you can deal with this and if you
can sometimes I'm like can we just we
just you know lip over it yeah can we
just do the show like but they do like
to do that but young with you there's no
I we all not professionally good at
drinking in the UK so I think over here
people have kind of more together when
they do go off the rails they go
probably losing heroine of was we're
just just gently drunk all the time oh
man well i did that i was at the solar
theatre a couple summers ago and we were
staying right down around there and i
could not believe how drunk everyone was
getting yeah you know because here you
go into a bar and the might be oh you
avoid those two people but there if
you're at eleven o'clock past 11 UK
everyone in the bar is just yelling
spitting telling stories getting ready
to sing or take their shirt off I mean
it's just like you can't be out for a
civilized glass of wine at eleven thirty
at night yeah you're right Annie in
central London when I finished a late
gig and I'm sober getting like the tube
or the bus home I just like you know you
just like I don't mind when you will
just so not in their wavelength everyone
is it's like they're yeah it's like
you're you're operating from another
dimension there in the drug zoo animal
dimension and you're just a person who's
in the universe with them you're the
only thing I do like actually is any
time Londoners will speak to each other
on the cheap is like after 11pm when
they're drunk no yeah you know what's
Carol with you mate and you guys
bag and then you can have a little nice
but you can have people are incredibly
irritating but you can also have read
women's one year what about the thing
that they can't I think it goes down
into the sidewalk at night but then
occur in the daytime and it comes up on
Friday Saturday nights that's like a
urinal on for size yeah but people like
guy it's it looks like a cone and it's
in the middle of the sidewalk and a guy
can go up and just kind of stick his
face in it so no one else can see your
face but they can totally see the back
of your body and you're just taking a
piss yeah that is one thing I've never
done that pic that is a level of drunk
confidence I've yet we are just having a
passion because you know if you if you
have to ever do it in public you only
choose like an alleyway and you know
Brown dumpster as you guys would say but
yeah so just confidently walk into the
middle of and then if I mean it shows
how little faith that the British police
and public have on the rest of the
public not just weighing everywhere so
they're like we just need to put some
toilets and middle well that's what I
was trying to say on stage and two
people in conversation like this is
crazy like that there's a toilet in the
street just go into this shop and I mean
go into the back of the bar and and use
their bathroom and they said no they
have to have those in the street
otherwise people will just pee
everywhere so the idea that that it
seems like there's no privacy there
those people would just be peeing on
that same spot if there was not that
thing like him give us the wire yes it's
like the hampsterdam for urination
remember there was a series where the
guy set up an area where it was legal to
do all drugs and just contain it oh yes
like what they've done that it on just
contain all the piss into the urine area
otherwise the whole place you get a
smoke it but so I immediately thought of
that scene and that thing when you were
talking about how in the UK marijuana is
the thing that you do when you're a
teenager and then you graduate yeah to
pull on drinking yeah yeah that's that's
what happens yeah that is an yeah the
weight thing is I think it's like such a
non thing now in the it's like
isn't it's not legal but you they're not
trying to read hours cops not gonna do
it it's like sort of it just doesn't
feel like the thing here now is everyone
seems to be boozing heavily cocaine and
and I think pills and all that have made
a big comeback and because it's so you
know dark and grungy and rainy the UK
it's very much people in little sweaty
bars and there's not the OpenNet I think
marijuana she's conducive to this open
go outside yeah it feels like a nice
kind of social floaty thing yeah yeah it
well especially here by the beach you
know to smoke event go swim or lay on
the sand or the ocean yes like it's it
feels like romantic was in the UK I
think yeah even smoking the UK's Dupre's
got to huddle outsides and cold sort of
I was really surprised at how many
people smoke over there though they
banned smoking but that means that
everybody has to smoke outside which
means that every time you cook like when
you're in a building there's no smoking
yeah but as soon as you walk out of the
building everyone is smoking oh yeah I
thought that's what it seemed like a way
that she because I the hair there was
just a fog around all the the density of
the you know the city that central
London and then the amount of people who
wanted to smoke it just felt like you
were smelling it all the time in a way
that you don't hear maybe because we're
more spread out or well no identities I
can you guys are I've seen very few
people smoke cigarettes you you can't
obviously smoke endorse it over no but
yeah you're right you don't see anyone
huddled out you see the odd person
having it so like 90 smoking for me it's
just a bleak in the UK again it's like a
way for getting our existence just take
the edge off the weather like I I don't
get how you want to make it sound so I
really thought London seems just kind of
vibrant and alive but I guess when
you're there all the time the rain it's
enough mix and ring I would give
anything to be a tourist from another
place coming to London sir I love to be
go longer two weeks you can walk
everywhere it's phenomenal but when you
were there all year and it gets too much
time here with you
you we were there in June I think well
obviously that's the prime time in
London in the summer is actually one of
the best places on earth but you get out
of those summer months you get to like
november december christmas is cool for
like that week anyway all your friends
are not working as we can hang out and
then you've got your just that gets dark
at 4pm every day yeah 4pm it gets dark
and in it because because of daylight
savings and the farmers owner why those
yeah I don't know why we do it here I
did people say it has to do with farming
but I don't understand why things that
why do I can't yeah well why can't the
farmers just do it an hour earlier allow
later yeah why do we all have to change
our clock I is a great like urban just
like thing like I'd farmers like no
one's even asked the I mean I could
come sure it wouldn't be difficult i
could just google why is it what is it
to do a farmers but was i got some
farmers yeah as i recall it's not as
easy to understand as bad once you start
reading about it you're like well still
i got questions for farmers yes one of
the navy makes yes I'd say yeah yeah get
a farmer on so and just grill them about
the clock like what the hell just go
like it's nice to be on a 11 or if you'd
have your way ten o'clock of you right
now here see I've got stuff I have to do
at a certain time of day but you're a
farmer it's just plants in the Sun so
you could get up what do you care if
it's four o'clock in the morning or
eight o'clock in the morning by your
watch you got to get up when the sun's
getting up anyway you should have a
meeting yeah yeah so you're killing me
they also got a bed really early in the
countryside so I mean like I think when
it gets dark yeah that's what they say
we're supposed to be doing go to bed
when it gets dark and get up when it
gets light I have to got a bit very
earlier there don't know why that is I
think it's because get maybe get up
earlier so I my wife is just it's kids
doing is we're in a pool house so that
we lit you have a bed it's small it's
basically like a shed oh that's right
you got a good setup though you're right
is very affordable but it's also very
formal because no one of a lie it's
probably about an extra fifty percent
bigger than the room we're in right now
which is your like kind of office yeah
and I'd say this is this room is about
as big as two king-size bed you know
like if you virtually forever in bed
sighs yeah yeah we have one king lucky
but everyone
king-size bed in it but I am I would say
this that one I don't know if I
mentioned this to you before but the one
thing I enjoy about living in a kind of
limited lifestyles it really makes you
change your gauge and success so before
I came out to our layers like you know I
want to live in the hills and a mansion
now I'm not I'd like to live in a place
where the bedroom is being enough I can
access the bed from both sides of the
bed yeah oh nice I'm climbing over my
wife every night to get into bed I like
a gentleman took the wall side so she
can get in and out quickly and go to the
bathroom was there a conversation or did
you it was it just assumed it was very
much too soon but I'm if I'm honest it
was one of those I'm a nice I'm a few
know quite a giving person I'm also been
a coward so on the bright side if an
attacker does come in she's busted she's
on the front she fishes on the front
line i'm hanging react oh yeah yeah just
for me though i I've got a I like to
stay hydrated I'm Kerri I've got to get
up a couple of times so does I do climb
over a lot but it's our own fault
because she wanted me right so she's
that she just had to deal with that if
you follow the leg but I turn the leg by
accident you know it's amazing the beast
but yeah I mean it's a very useful
starting point for LA but it has come on
her go into this top where this is
something that we led into this with and
that was the point I was making anyway
so everything's a win from there
everything is a win yeah yeah I just
want to you know have not a toaster oven
which is what we use at the moment as
our magic which is something i've never
had in my life normally I can normal
enough space for a toaster hand an oven
but I'd see consolidate both of them
well we we just made the move from world
just make this a couple years ago we
made the move from toaster to toaster
oven I rush that's an upgraded it well
you also have a rail of it we also have
a real love in the f50 hoster oven the
benefit of that over the toaster is that
you can do some other things and the
toasters where we were going through
toasters really we'd be doing just like
I don't know my wife you know when
you've got another little slice we had
the to slice but it was a super actually
we had one it was one slice but it was
really why once and long oh you can tell
you can get to three piece pieces of
bread help Tony sliced
yeah yeah but we had that and we had
another one before that and the whatever
the coils were in the toaster were not
as durable listed is the heat element in
the toaster oven the toaster oven has
proved more long live the toaster was
they were flaking out in under a year
was it may be your technique of getting
it out and flicking it up because I a
sore think that sometimes I worry of my
toaster them and I get quite good
because when it's a two shorter piece of
bread and you can't i dunno with your
I'm not a knife in the toaster guy and
I'm paranoid but I know when it's off
you probably can't get bird but I don't
like putting a knife in the toaster to
get my toast I'd unplug it if I was
going to do that yeah well I but there's
these maniacs out there just it's once
it's off they do though I just think I
don't trust these things yeah well I go
fresh you were a few of those guys over
there they were dying breed yeah natural
selection is greatest I go for a heavy
flick but I do wonder if that takes
punishment on the toast and the
mechanism yeah well my wife it's funny
with wives or relationships I'm sure it
is with them too there's the thing that
you would say to them like maybe there's
a better way to do what you're doing and
then there's the other stuff we just go
look pets we're just going to have to
buy more toasters because of that ya
know she has a mechanical thing like
when I see it when I what I'm sitting
next to her and she's on her laptop the
the energy that she puts into to banging
the keys down I'm like look you just die
right there it's one electric electronic
thing that's trying to touch another
electronic thing so you'd really for the
life of the machine it would be a good
exercise to see how lightly you can
touch it and still get it to print a
letter she lost a couple that she lost a
couple of a cable before because I
speaker always made me laugh I don't how
you how aggressively you're pressing
letters lost it or or it's like it what
doesn't work like that you can't tie
Patti anymore we had that happen really
really hate tease one if you're going to
hit a letter you get it well it's the
most common one that's the one that's
going to go out right the one that's
taking the abuse only the end of a word
Christ right bang but like she has it's
the one she's typing it sometimes and
I'm sitting next to her reading or
whatever it
sounds like it just feels like she's
like you're not more emphatic the harder
you hit the key if it doesn't matter
yeah how hard you hit the key but that's
something that I've learned by making
the mistake that I should not just that
insist just like look if we have to buy
you a new laptop because of that that's
one of the things that's the price of
doing business I had a good and I don't
want it to be two men talking about
they're the ones getting annoyed but and
I will mention this is just the funny
feedback 1 i'd like to yesterday my wife
is an amazing person but she's very
under wife like in many in a traditional
sensors and I am I I just cook mainly if
we're going to do any cooking well
basically that the people in the big
house we're staying are away for weeks
we have access to the main kitchen so
then a Monday she just invited two of
her friends around and she was out to it
can you just cook us all of me at 24
hours you said can you I've just invited
my keys cook us all the meal okay I'll
do that that's fine what did you make I
made a red curry a vegan red curry with
tofu yeah quite it's not too hard to
make quite good for a few people uh-huh
one of my friends has loads of allergies
like as in she can't eat like loads of
stuff so she was like she'll have rice
and don't worry about her that's what
she said to me she comes back just
before they get there and I'm like made
most of it I'm entering do you get
Angelo anything and we just have said
don't worry about you chennai was a very
specific i wish it well so she was kind
of annoyed about that a little bit and
then wow so she's like the president and
you're her you're her name is there
something in this instance that was very
much the role that was happening mm-hmm
and then if you and I got annoyed
because she and her friends coming to
I'm a nice guy and he's a food guy like
sorts of foods i'm thinking i don't cut
loads when I don't it's nice to sort
impress people isn't it girl look what I
did for you well you'd like it to be
delicious you don't want people to come
over and then you just open a can of
spaghetti sauce exactly so you think
I've you know maybe he's coming back
later and then I made it a bit spicy so
I sort of format as I'm spicy about this
putting just x y&z sugar in it
and I read you could put some peanut
butter just peanut peanut butter in my
son's making it mild cut him down cut it
down so you know she's emigrants bit
spicy is she tasted this might i'll bet
some peanut butter / then in my head guy
she asked if his am ago i had any
allergies but she hadn't mentioned our
meals you can see where this is going
Jake he comes in he one thing he's
allergic to his peanuts and literally
like five minutes before that I put
peanut and sounds like and you put it in
to accommodate him to make it less spicy
pie me know yeah I was being a giving
person but and she goes things I did but
he was like really cool about it and she
was like god I forgot what I was
thinking I'm annoyed cuz should've are
you know you got I should have asked
just to double check but then I'm going
she should anyway it was fine they would
call about it and then I was like you to
have rice and then there was this extra
zucchini stuff in the fridge no basic
made it I'll understand have rice and
then Hannah goes looking for innocent
engineering there you go only can have
that and then having us how can you just
kick the neck just please just cook them
that as well Mike don't go I find you
could easily you could easy just fry
some of that in five minutes do that
they're happy that the two guests go
away after we've eaten and Hannah goes
eat you annoyed me a bit and I might you
know you go it's fine beautiful I felt
like an for messing up his food
because it even though they're not
really anyone thought like an so
she won't just be honest to me be honest
maybe a bit ago I'm a bit annoyed but I
also you know I know the city and then
she got furious died message of being a
noida oh that we had the aisle metra
that I'll be far that's not okay i don't
think that's okay for robbing me to go
she goes you are exams no no no it's
fine it's fine like you know in the only
human level it's just annoying isn't on
a human level to have that all go that's
it so well yeah I don't know there's a
lot of things about this story that I'm
ready to weigh in on deck okay jump in I
made a lot of your listeners that
probably stop that covers a very tedious
and that was such a personal boring
spouse paste argument conversation
there's a lot of people struggling with
relationships with other human beings
out there like how I really enjoyed that
over there yeah in waiting I feel like
in interpersonal relationships like that
it's the
a shin is the hardest thing so the last
thing that you mentioned is the first
foul it's like look if we were trying to
get along if I'm not telling you that
I'm annoyed and you want me to not be
annoyed and don't ask if I'm annoyed
just because I'm doing a bad job of
hiding it because i am trying to I'm
trying to shield you from that then when
I when you paint me to say it and then
get mad at me except now you've trained
me to do the exact opposite thing
because what I'm trying to do is get
better at hiding my true feelings from
you yeah and and you're not reinforcing
that possibly kiddo we're she being
right at and said well how did you two
just I would have been out of a nervous
because because you were doing what she
wanted originally which is which is not
letting her know that you were a little
bit of noise yeah and then but the other
thing is what people coming over for
dinner I feel like yes you've got to
tell me if you've got dietary
restrictions first of all but if it's
vegan if you're vegan that's one thing
but if someone else is vegan then it
then it's like well look I don't know
how to make vegan dinner so it's going
to be not so good when you come over
because this is going to be my first
shot at making something yeah but they
Michael they like that the girl who was
very large it was like don't worry about
me like then i do the same like I just
don't worry I'm not going to put that
pressure on me so that was they were
cool but they were both allergic so this
is basically you could have just made a
nice dinner for your wife and let them
bring up any weapons are made say they
will watch me my wifey did it say it's
like it was like they got given a much
worse version of warrior having in the
end and they were very completely calm
and they didn't care but you know you
felt like and even I was like May don't
care so I shouldn't care but I just felt
like a weird senses like when he stopped
cooking no matter how chilled you I
stopped taking a bit of pride in it so
I'm were pride dented by the flat lights
and also going I don't know we put
peanut butter in us that was like an
anomaly of a situation and it means like
a crap when you were telling the story
that was like oh that was a part of the
story of it was quick Chevy and I didn't
really understand it's like this is a
chef trick of putting peanut butter
because you used it before and it has is
good take the spice their pad thai like
where you can eat it and pad thai
because that's already got a little bit
of a nice place
peanuts on it if you don't have peanuts
that you want the honest Skrine and
downs for the peanut butter and it also
i think i've done it with a couple other
things but a peanut butter on a source
just gives it a nice fitness and takes
the the kick out of it but no it's all
fine but it was just this is such a
funny like I find it so funny when my
wife is I just find it funny when she's
angry because it just she's the most
sweet beautiful loving person we get on
so well most of the time then suddenly
to just get angry her depression it just
makes me like a paradoxical thing isn't
it just be shouting at someone for like
getting annoyed at song it well it's I
feel like it that's one of the
challenges that we're we're not in my
marriage we're trying to just take it a
little bit easier on each other right
you know it's like look you are the
person that I love the most I'm the
person that you love the most so it's we
don't need the Spurs and the whip and
the riding crop and they you know I'm
already trying my best to anticipate
what you want and then do that so if I
make a mistake you don't have to yell at
me because it's I did I didn't do i'm
not doing it on purpose it's just an
accident I'm with you on that misty it's
the getting annoyed the mistake so then
in ironically I mean me being annoyed
she'd mistakenly forget to tell me is
slightly hypocritical because I do
awesome guy like I wasn't trying to be
an I just accidentally was an
in that situation so well if
yeah well now to go back now to really
go forensic and get friends it my year
almost overall I think to just go back
to the original part of the stood the
premises I i I'm your wife I'm inviting
over two of my friends and just assuming
that you're going to make them dinner
yeah that was a funny that was a one
that I just went with but you go like
you know and you want to go if I just
just a map I'm at that lender
patriarchal guilt of them that thinks
what rounds maybe like inviting myself
you're cooking love that yeah we know UK
I don't think you can do that yeah I
don't know what I would do exactly in
that situation I just say out loud this
is what's so so you're inviting your
friends over and and I'm going to make
them dinner that's what's that's what's
happening yeah that what we're doing
yeah I what and what
what kind of a mint give a menu that
you'd like I mean yeah we're grocery
list or do you just want to tell me what
we're eating and then I'll go and figure
out how to make yeah there is no it was
just can you saw that okay you have just
touched another thing I think very
amazing in relationships my friend Matt
made me really i doing he does is so
your communication is such an important
one of most important things in a
relationship yeah okay and I'm a really
good one I've noticed that he does I do
is when you have some guests you can't
just um you know I don't know what age
it is a growth you can't just have
guests in your house without sort of
running it past the person you love you
can't just pick up this come over there
be like five of your friends in the
house because that's just I don't know
that's just like against the rule that's
what there's no rule this but that would
be just bizarre to not know about that
there can be I feel like you can have an
accidental spontaneous there has to be a
story than afterwards like how come
these five people are here you didn't
you didn't invite them over it's like no
no I went down to the store and then I
saw Steve and I said come over and then
his wife was picking up their bubble
blah and few you know so if you've got a
plausible story of how the Conte me a
story for 55 July but my mouth and the
one is a few of us had to stay at his
before getting a really early flight to
meet or bust the airport the next day
and he good hey guys here comes to mind
and they needed that thing where the
next day he really didn't run it past
his wife so he went can hey just
checking before I invite my friends
around can they all come and stay ours
on this day as a classic if she got with
the check is working out on that he
would get a you'd fail that because you
go I was fun of just you suddenly agreed
to placate your friends who you also
like and then you gotta I'm not so
you guys do but he was asking her as if
he hadn't am already won this way you go
you off if you haven't asked assuming
she's getting oh yes but there's an
embarrassing moment if you guys that's
not cool when you're set to go oh yeah
after this you're a website to see that
yes well then you have to go back to the
first people and you say look I
committed or or you order you just say
to you or you say to your wife look I
I was trying to be nice and ask you but
I really do not not not the hollows
because my wife will do the opposite
thing sometimes she'll ask me what of
two options I would prefer and then once
I tell her then she'll reveal that she
really wants the other one and start
making a case for and then I and my
thing with that is like look I don't
really care which of these two things
we're gonna do but now you put me in a
situation where I feel as though I made
a choice and I was not allowed to make a
choice it'd be much better if I get to
be the hero and just you I say to you
you decide and then we'll do what you
want as opposed to know I decide but I
get overruled that feels bad yes she
she'll do that sometimes that's one of
the ones that I've said please don't ask
me if you've got one that you really
want don't ask me just betting that I'll
pick the right answer is it jerkin
success together like we say singla and
then nine items I guess we're not as
similar as I thought no I think in her
mind she wants me to feel like I have
control but she doesn't but she still
wants me to do what she wants me to do
so in her mind she think so Oh doing him
a favor because if he chooses the same
thing as me he'll feel like that was his
choice and that'll feel good to him and
my thing is like if I don't really have
the choice then just tell me because
most of the time I'd rather just I'd
rather that be my quality my quality is
that I let you I'm I'm just a really
accommodating guy yes and I can have
five people over during the day when
she's gone I can do what I want probably
people can come up as long as they're
gone and I've cleaned up yes yes and
it's still funny when it's like you're a
grown-up you don't advance this is too
personal but have you ever because I'll
tell you why we did one session of
marriage counseling and you've ever done
it but I actually really recommend it we
did it because we got married in the
Catholic Church Hannah's family's
Catholic and I'm I just think you know
the windows look cool so let's do that I
me like I'm accommodating I don't if
someone leaves in a thing and a mum sort
of philippines and it means a lot and
she actually baptizing I'm just
yes I've got atheist made two of them at
LIGO couldn't do i okay i guess i just
you i mean like it's important to them I
mean I really don't know I'm Jill's than
beer then it's got to go the important
one yeah as long as you don't have to
kill a chicken or something like there I
know you're that weird form of
Christianity other word that's what I
don't know a killer chicka don't have
marriage can be alright though that's
part of the marriage counseling actually
can you can you slaughter this chicken
and who who does the nekkid leaders that
are no so part of it was if you give it
depending on how it's sort of into the
faith the Catholic sector doing it with
our yes to do them my friend and his
wife of both actually caffeinated a
class where had a whole day of learning
about marriage as a Catholic and being
Catholic and so there's an interesting
array of very Catholic couples who like
some people probably know sexiful
marriage some people at them probably
you know one person helping everyone out
the due to scheduling or scheduling a
common but how you guys saying how we're
so scheduling I think but I think well I
think we're sophisticated enough yeah
well I'm saying shut out with only our
transit I had to I had to fix the high
street thing so I think you know get on
things are doing Mia just let ya let it
go and we couldn't do any end so we got
instead an hour where to fill in a
questionnaire like a like a sort of set
question imagine it like multiple choice
about how we feel about each other and
all this like does it annoy you and your
partner does this is or anything do you
believe your part do you love your
partner's job choices but she support
you and then we'd go and see a priest
who was also marriage counselor for an
hour it was amazing firstly on the way
there we had a massive argument about
common waters about likely she arguing
in the car till we went in there we
don't argue as much as I'm making a
sound by the way but we're going was it
about the multiple choice no no no
please no what we written and this is
what you're describing now is used to be
a kind of a game show here in the United
States called the newlywed game I really
love you ever well I haven't seen it the
host they'd have three couples and the
premise of the game was
whoever knows the other their their new
spouse the best is going to win a washer
dryer or whatever you know a prize that
they've said that they want for their
new home either it's a what any would
always be a washing machine or a
dishwasher and the king size bedroom set
or something like that but Jay would ski
they would invite they would the
husband's go to a soundproof booth and
the host would ask the wives questions
like what's his favorite or if he has a
saturday free what's he going to do or
what's the favorite room in the house
where you would there phrases make
whoopee you know okay yeah and then
front and then and then the the spouse
would come in and then they get there
and what's your favorite room to do that
in the honey bedroom is well right but
they may be actually choosing in their
own house they are newlyweds you oh yes
he'll na so it can j well that was just
an example yeah yeah maybe it would be
maybe then the question what you're
right so maybe the question would be
other than the bedroom i can today that
makes more sense so so then they'd
invite the other spouse out and then
they'd ask them the questions and they
would answer in front of the audience
who's already seen the first answer and
then the woman would flip over the bride
flip over the answer and then they do it
the other way around and so so it's very
similar to what the Catholic Church is
putting you through we actually want to
wash your dryer at the end of it yeah
well that's great we got a good marriage
of the Catholic Church we got free
washer dryer yeah it's because our
favorite rooms have sexy was there and
what was a couple counseling like I'm
sorry because I know that was a little
side no no no no I thought I was a you
know I love a tangent warm anyone and so
we it was really good we edit and
actually he gave us the results and said
actually we're very we scored very
highly very like well matched there's a
couple little things we brought up in it
like about coming but it was like I
think I'm honest and I like I like it
when she has her own hobbies and friends
and sometimes I feel like she puts too
much i'm just doing stuff with me and
then got to speak about it in the open
with him kind of it was nice to bring
them up without feeling like you're
being judged and then I interestingly
that's one of the common he didn't give
us a diagram it looked like it was like
from the 50s or something was this weird
speech bubble in like there was the
ground and underneath the like different
levels of
ground relating to the man and the woman
and its really interesting how common a
lot of these gripes are men mens gripes
with women women's or men's and most
common ones he said were women's main
problem with men is their lack lack of
ability to communicate and that sort of
thing and the man's one Ward's feeling
like the woman wants him to be better
like not being good enough and that's it
lack of acceptance does it not being
accepted was the man's problem with what
the woman had in the woman's was the
communicator demand and those are
probably most common ones which i'm sure
you're male or female listeners who
relationships will be like oh yeah
that's it yeah I don't know do you think
do you find that to be it's not a live
no lack of acceptance is maybe it's not
the right term but there's a i'm trying
to think it's like you know like you
said oh you make a mistake if she makes
me second generally apart from old nut
gate last night okay you made a mistake
but I find sometimes like you said you
make a mistake and they'll be come on
really you always do that anything you
know it doesn't mean to well the other
thing is you've got to accept I think
that you're dealing with another person
I mean no matter how great you get along
with your best friend your best comedian
friend Carl yeah I don't know if he what
is you bet he's my best comedian I'm
glad that you were able to say that like
it's because he may be listening to this
year I'll send in the link that's going
to make him feel better but no matter
how how well you get along with that
person in your life men or women
whatever your your best other than your
spouse friend is if you had to spend all
the time with all that you do with them
that you do with your spouse and eat
meals and provide save money for the
future all those other things that you
do you would you have conflicts quite
some cool sometimes I think my wife
holds us to it like she'll be saying
look we've got to be nicer to each other
maybe we need to and I said look I'm
really working on that first of all but
second of all no matter the dalai lama
in the
hope would eventually have some conflict
so to really funny yeah that's a good
sitcom yeah they get this pitch down
yeah I don't know to out pitch it to a
channel Pope versus poke doses daylight
mm-hmm in a cave or the Vatican well
that's the other thing I mean it's
almost a hack premise but the idea that
they that the Catholic priest is giving
you marriage advice I mean true he's
probably observed a lot of marriages
that's very true but how many has he
participated in I think he was married
actually you can you can imagine the
Catholic priests no not up your Catholic
Church of England you can i'm pretty
sure maybe wasn't we're in his house and
I just assumed he had a wife but that is
what was in there now I don't meet here
if separable Catherine maybe wife hasn't
even Catholic yeah I mean this is
happiness there was a picture of Jesus
in the building and I usually see you
that's all I really paid attention see
it was a notable sorry yeah we cut your
I cut you off then you're saying oh yeah
of course is going to be conflict in a I
think people get to if it's all the time
and there's no I think it's well it's
outweighing the good times afterwards
well I think a big part of marriage
relationship that way there is how you
resolve that how do you discuss it what
do you do when one person is feeling put
upon I I was going to say that's that
with my wife and I one of the big things
is one of us to do or the other one
doesn't feel like they're being
appreciated you know not that you're
keeping score on everything you do but
it's like I'll look I made dinner for
your two friends who came over and and
then now you're asking me to do that
again wow I don't see the gratitude in
terms of like when it went not that
there has to always be a payback this to
that but sometimes you feel like I look
I didn't say thank you for that or you
didn't you didn't do something that
makes me feel like you appreciate what
I'm doing that's an interesting when I
got told by someone recently hid red men
are from mars women from venus he
actually read it because he's he's
recently married and I think he was red
and oh my god as it's a straight an
interesting
is it guys do this is I think I can kind
of relate to is you can't keep points
cause of what unit so i can be like each
day you know like try be nicer general
you can't put extra value so i can't be
like if today she fills up a water
bottle for me that i can i would put
next to my side of the bed if it was a
side next to my bed i can put it hmm a
shelf behind your head ah i can't be
like when i get 5,000 points for
yesterday's meal and you get 10 points
of that I think it just has to be a nice
gestures a nice gesture and you can't
yeah well it's more of its more of an
ongoing feeling yeah and you want to
kind of try as much as you can to not
think of it like that it's late aboard I
would be smashing it may I beetle well I
think both people want it i think for it
to work really well both people want to
feel like they're trying hard to win in
terms of being the nicest to the other
person yes if you're both trying to do
another nice thing for them and not
concerned about what you're getting in
return then it's all going to work out
fine yes it's when it it's how do you
handle when it feels when it feels like
something's out of kilter when you when
you're into that conflict zone how do
you bring it up and and what do you do
for example do you say I think that
you're mad at me and then get them to
admit it and then light them up as soon
as they say because that's what happened
to you yeah i did i'm having a go at
your wife yeah I appreciate ya right
back in each other yeah because we're
new friends and I feel like that Zoe
that's American you know I don't know if
you saw the sopranos but when someone
screws with one of us I did they got a
deal with all of us you know I don't
what we're gonna say to my wife nice you
could add up at the back oh this is it
business as far as I think this video
old oh yeah what's her face what was
that the Christopher's girlfriend was
released I don't want to slow yeah that
was so well I don't think you can spoil
your also noting that it is oh yeah no
you can't um that's that's very
interesting well tell you what I was
just thinking what we were talkin
talking you know a thing that could
happen is we could get together for a
meal that'd be good yeah I would like
that I know as a double date yeah yeah I
don't I'm saying not you and I and our
and our wives
I'll do is I'll if you give me 24 hours
notice I'll tell my wife Jake and his
wife coming over cook us something's
more oh and see what how she reacts to
that that would be great well we're not
allergic to anything so that's good but
I was thinking I was thinking the
opposite that you could come over here
and I could make something that I know
your wife is allergic to yes she hates
cheese yeah really yeah they're true
weirdly and so do to my things on any
cheese but what are you are you so
you're vegan I'm Carl totally my best
friend comet is a full vegan that's my
leather and I try to be vegan but
occasionally slightly I mean it's
annoying you have to give it a label
because then people when you're not a
vegan vegan I'm trying to be pretty
vegan and occasionally something has
some stuff in it well as a bit of
arrogance something and I just roll with
it because who are we making these rules
for I'm trying to be a better person for
the world as much as I can be and I'm
gonna fight if I put myself in this
strict bracket all the time I'm just
gonna I'm gonna disappoint myself well
the reality is a gray area right I mean
yes I would say if you've got a physical
alert allergy to something I mean I'm
not a but uh but it for environmental
reasons if that's why you're doing it
you know my wife is a big
environmentalist great and so we're
trying to eat less meat basket so that's
I know they have the meatless Monday
thing which is no we're not systematic
in that way about it but we'd much less
meat than we used to but I feel like
yeah and let when you get to that
intensity of the philosophical depths of
veganism where you can't eat anywhere
unless you're at home that gets
complicated I exactly's i just-i can't--
confident so that should she prayed me
having this diet we both bonded in fact
we both don't like cheese just just
don't like it which cheese lovers cannot
understand yeah no you're right now
they've always on me to leave no but I'm
thinking about selling the data we
should try we should go to a restaurant
first where we can where we can both be
sure that we're going to be able to be
happy yes
because i'm just i'm seeing mistakes
that we could make because one of the
things my wife's go to move if people
are coming over just break out the
cheese right where you can break out
that's fine that's not the only it's not
that it's not just a cheese ball to the
hole man we're so clueless like when we
will if we had to think hummus there you
go I just gotta do this right so you
come over we get out the cheese and
crackers get some hummus out that was
wrong with there's no chicken or beef in
the crackers reset Keith crackers yeah I
don't mean it America mate you guys put
what why don't I have a date to weird
food items and sorry to always do
America's ice princess but this isn't
common for America but with the cheese
thing at The Improv ordered some
vegetable fat goes told the guy I was
vegan to make it easier there was just
secret cheese crumbled on top of it
there's just cheese on it I mentioned on
the menu cheese yeah for me you've got
something boiling pot cheating or
something you've gotta mention you can't
just assume people everyone's going to
be down with cheese well and when you
dig into someone in California you'd
like to think that they know what the
hell you're talking he was an older dude
he kind of was like you know most people
here or so like yeah that's cool but he
just kind of look like I like to just
serve the people well you got an accent
he thought so oh you're vegan that's
like being you know Venezuela bit yeah
yes oh he's from that part of the UK
vegan bigger here he's from vegan ville
all right ok cool and the other one this
was malicious bazaar by anyone's
standards was in Little Tokyo town
little tokyo in downtown sure yeah went
to a bar ordered some cashews and inside
the cashews they had dry fish heads like
a tiny tiny dried fish heads unmentioned
as well no inside of case they was like
a bowl of kashi not spice it was it was
an Asian spice nut mix and they put they
put that a little little tiny fish
behind fish fish bits and fish it like
fish head with I like very tiny for it's
really tiny but it was still other eyes
and this yeah you don't even think I
didn't feel me yeah there seems to be
little fan of Isis in the
not see it as a face you've got to
mention the face yeah fair can't
secretly unique a face in there assuming
everyone's down with fish basis yeah no
you're right but that's not i'm not
saying whatever in America doesn't that
was a specific bet and ethnicity of food
that is a nemesis there was there is
nothing once you go once you're dealing
with the cuisine of other countries I
don't think you can blame America I mean
we're a melting pot but we can't take
responsibility for everybody else you
can G that's why the band's happening
late to stop to stop fish heads I don't
think that I you know that's maybe Trump
went in there he was authorized in it
this is it there's no way I'm getting I
can't take this face believe nice this
is very Omega vodka back me up on this
yeah it was out of hands don't make more
sense and a lot of the reasoning behind
a lot of these policies oh well that's
another better well that's a good way
let's let's bring it around so because
we're getting to the time of I've gotta
you gotta we've got other things but I
wanted to ask you about and then and
then have you on again if you're around
how so talk about talk about why in here
what's brought you to America oh my wife
is an actor and she has a manager here
kept saying company you gotta come over
be here for six months and I I was an
American accent you were doing thanks
man right I mean you did it yeah I know
I know I know I've got a I've got a
casting in about an hour and a half
where I don't think they'll ask me to do
the accident I have to be ready to do
but it's just some dumb costume anyway
to do the American actor well I just be
ready in case they go hey man can you do
it and like yeah but then it's when I'm
not self-conscious about I can kind of
do it but it's it's more than know
everything here well my wife's advice
I'm pretty sure she's not here right now
would be to come in without with with
your American accent and then do
yourself afterwards because if you do
the American accent later they all know
it they'll know that you're doing it
that's interesting i've heard mixed
things I've had the outside thing like I
don't know you really like and then what
you can get bills I don't think is any
lines in this I think it's just no lines
i think it's i think the header is me
shopping so just avoid the fish
and the cheese that's why I want to be
my over there you go so um k made I came
in turn are beginning 2015 for like a
couple of weeks that a couple of shows
really liked just really like the city
and the vibe I like they're outdoors
eNOS of it like the web they were like
the healthiness of it and and yeah I
want to make it and then so we're going
to come over it i've got to go back to
the UK to edinburgh festival but
otherwise i have a visa and was that
hard to get it was it's a lot of admin
involved so it takes a few months you've
got to get people to write letter saying
you're amazing literally like that level
of talking up and in that too they from
the industry and you've got work yeah
and I had some work lined up and all
things comedy actually our podcast
fathers who we are on and there's no
part of the that actually they help with
that a lot because I'm over here are you
getting paid by them I'm not well yeah
yeah what it's you know this future we
can't it can end up with the podcast you
know what it's like if you get to a
level that can be another life shows you
can do right hand sure so yeah and and
yes so we wanted to give it like a kind
of three year don't I we've been I've
been in London on my life pretty much
together I see that's a good age to do
that for l by motorbike you know let's
keep it mmm yeah I'd say that's about
that's about right I was in there
somewhere I wrote a motorcycle I had a
10-year period where I had motorcycles I
really i mean i don't i think i'm too
scared to actually ride a motorbike but
i would maybe one of those scooters that
has three wheels you know the ones I've
two at the front of one of the back I I
think he'd be happier with two wheels I
think because you can do normally you're
a little more maneuverable and and and I
go and but I think your instinctive
going smaller but I'd get a motorcycle
but I'd get a smaller one right and then
because then you can flick around it's
all about being able to get out of
situation Lena's I that's why I got off
I felt like I'd look I've been in the
casino for 10 years and I walked out
with all my money yeah you know you
never got one accident
no that's right here is every personal
amoeba has an excellent and that means
that is now alive I've been spreading
like it's well that's what they say
there's two kinds of motorcyclist guys
have been down and goes who haven't been
down yet I mean form Sunday I mean I'm
not in certain things in life I'm not
really and that's what I'm like I don't
need that I don't need that stress i'll
do something i'll just have an affair
that's the other thing you do any 40
isn't it yeah it's a pole I don't think
I'll deal I mean you see how much
trouble I got into the old up the
wrong you made the you put nuts in the
dinner yes you have you effect was
another lady let every big trouble or a
man he's mad yeah I put nuts in a man
come on Oh hits it out for a pump nope
no it's not you and it's loud too late
not only was that a pun though it was
like a ridiculous like how like is it
not to work women to work it out like if
I said okay you said it now you have to
do it how would you do it you'd have to
put your nuts out right I mean that's
the only way i can imagine it can you
get your nuts in a man's but i don't
think you can do it okay but I don't
want to know people listening I don't
want to go which thought you could add a
squirrel or something way to be like
some weird sexual believers the school
as we peer not sort of goes back
slightly store them for the winter oh my
god it's gotta be there so many ways you
could hurt yourself doing that I mean
right sorry it's such a high level of
trust oh my god you'd have to RIT you
have to out there get scared and just
really climbed them in there there we go
relaxed for the whole thing yeah in that
scenario in that scenario I think I
think he'd rather be the nut the note or
the button night it wouldn't hit be
rather be the butler or not when that
one so it's so very seldom and in
insects that you'd rather be the button
than that and I think we found the one
Chico's to being the bar if you're in
prison someone makes you your you
are happy be a but I'm exclusively
a nuts and but Mitch that's my so if
you're a good that word everything's
getting off on that though okay the
squirrel this girl
sorry that's really hit me that that
shows my might I talk to north at
marriage and relationships in kind of
seriously yeah it's nice that we got
around to it tonight that we got around
to it so talk about talk about how so
people are listening to this then they
say oh chris martin not the guy from
nola Guiton Coldplay I mean in the
Philippines really that guy I've got a
lot of tweets from Filipinos oh because
they thank you though yeah I got I
verified take on to its earnest all its
cause this me to have 2,000 indian
people following me because they thought
i was in Coldplay and then subsequently
a change my profile photos that have
them say not in Coldplay and then Indian
people found that funny and then now
that's gone so then followed by Indians
think it's funny that my name is chris
martin and then two days ago i think he
was in manila and i had but even just to
have a lot of followers just take it
take it real win if i could get a
thousand yeah pity followers I'm all
about the pity follow I'm all about the
Filipino fans more syrupy know I've been
you know maybe I could put on an
impromptu you gag out there seeing a
family kill two birds so what is your
twitter handle chris n comedy again
these thing that that you're trying to
I'm trying to not be in Coldplay you
know this is Chris Martin from Coldplay
is comedy Twitter yeah I mean this is
here people don't pay attention to them
it's a Christian comedy and the podcast
study with Carl which has is not
suitable for this in terms of we could
be talking about sanctity of marriage we
can also feed talking about the squirrel
you never yes yes you're going to leave
things open you've gotta leave things
and we all believe is open which is what
you said to someone while stirring the
school it's called the caldonian Chris
Martin comedy podcast because we named
it ages ago before we were as you said
like a catchy name so we just made it a
really long title and put both our names
in it right poor memes just put Carl
Donnelly and chris martin into any kind
of pendulum machine it's going to come
up and it should hopefully not find
Coldplay ship on the podcast and thence
there a website where people can find
out your comedy gig so do you have any
comedy gigs in the States how much he
doing
doing flappers tomorrow night and I'm
doing but you this might just won't come
out until next week this will be I've
got i'll actually did some shows in Salt
Lake City we are featuring for Bert
Kreischer how greatly fun to do and oh
I'd love to I mean Bert's grace yeah and
good see you guys both together there
will be off every fun actually so that's
in Salt Lake City when this comes out i
guess that weekend 30 to the 50 and then
i'm back often new zealand's for a month
for them back and then yet chris chris
martin comedy door code at UK ok they
can find chris martin comedy on the
internet for that although there's some
up there's summary old guy who's like a
open mic ER called chris martin and he
got I just went to do a gig of the ice
house and the listing it listed all him
is all his listing hola like an old
bearded guy who I think did comedy and
maybe doesn't do comedy anymore hmm
weird they go basically I should a
change my name is the more of a story
but it's too late i'm too far in now
well you would have already been a grown
up getting busy doing your own thing
before chris martin became super famous
mean he was famous when i started bar i
I just didn't like the sound of a joke
hard to give up your name I thought I'd
put my middle name in chris john martin
and i stopped after five gigs not cuz I
thought this unpretentious cuz that his
middle name is also John so that's one
of his in LA CJ CJ CJ house to American
for me yeah CJ Martin Louie CK you know
thing that's kind of CJ yeah well Louise
name is actually not it's pronounced ck
and now it is CK but his last name is
some crazy Polish name yeah yeah I don't
know if you've ever heard that story but
it's a good story historian here to hit
a gym coach who would always say his
name wrong and it was very upsetting to
Louie and and Louie thought the guy was
doing it on purpose to screw with him
and then he Louie explain how to
actually say it and the coach was like
oh I'll fix that and he just put the
letters ck on his jersey and from then
on everybody said his name right and it
was like this genius solution from the
sky who and I hope I'm I hope
not miss remembering this story because
it's Lois story someone but it was just
it was a real great story about
asserting yourself telling telling
someone what your problem is
articulating it even even if it's
someone who you think is going to be
unsympathetic and then having it to that
person turned out to be surprisingly the
person that solves this problem for you
for the rest of your life that's good
yeah and it's a great it's a great call
this a great name no one doesn't known
for getting that name louis ck well he's
also super talented girls echoing
ferocious special this morning and it is
fantastic I mean I don't know why any to
plug his pursuit I wonder where he's
were in the car my goddess yeah I know
it's just I he's so good there's some
stuff in it that me and Carl are
actually what's that thing about its
name he talks about magic mike the film
yeah 10 minutes and i have half written
a routine about how much i love it and
Carl also has a story that would mean
him hosted a weird we love that film we
put on a weird evening where we hosted
Magic Mike and I don't know why we did
it with and then some like loads of
women came to watch Magic Mike and these
two guys know were like introducing
magic might like week with the directors
of it and he said he did it on Monday
then he saw this and that the magic
might he's done if you think I'm pretty
I'm pretty original talking about magic
Michaels it's like I'm talking about men
and women you think yeah and then he
does like a 10 minute routine of it but
it's great so you can't because you know
all right well good I'm glad that we
were able to plug Louie but yeah he
needs it happy to help Louie happy to
help you're welcome I'll see who /
you're my vegan curry alright so i think
i like to end with a high five ah that's
Tiffany man thanks buddy I was alright
real fun awesome yeah it was a good time
don't give up there'll be plenty of time
to give up later that's the thing that I
say and then and then I play this
[Music]
you heard that you heard that you've
heard that you heard that you heard that
you heard that you've heard that you
heard that you've heard that you heard
that you heard that you heard that
you've heard that you heard that